Цьому селу більше ніж 250 років.
Нам ніколи не розповідали,
що в Іванівці була козацька застава,
нам не розповідали, що про озера геройські
соленосні знав ще Геродот і писав про це.
Коли ми вчились в школі,
історія України була такою тоненькою книжечкою.
І все цікаве було десь там
в Парижі, в Москві, в Нью-Йорку, в Києві.
А тут ніби нічого, а що у вас там? Степ і все.
Так само, як нам казали тоді київські журналісти:
«Ой, у вас там шось є цікаве?»
І може тому, що ми відразу
після закінчення школи поїхали з дому,
ну і жили по світах, і за кордоном, і ніби все було гарно.
А от не вистачало...
Рідного не вистачало, і ми до рідного повернулися.
Перший етап – це до Херсону,
і другий етап – сюди.
Ми жили тут колись, тут пройшло наше дитинство,
це – рідне село мого чоловіка.
Я жила в селі неподалік, 9 кілометрів звідси
В 10 класі ми сиділи за однією партою.
В один день і один місяць народилися.
Тільки різні роки.
І от ми приїхали,
і ніби ми повинні були сюди повернутися.
Отак. Я ж кажу, просто так нічого не буває.
Ми для себе відкрили цю місцевість,
і почали її відкривати для всіх.
Ця хата раритетна,
їй десь років під 80 років, а може і більше.
І що цікаво: ми назвали свою садибу «Марійкина»
на честь нашої молодшої доньки.
І потім ми вже тут устаткувалися,
вже почали жити, працювати,
і ми дізналися, що перша господиня цієї хати,
її також звали Марія.
І вже є такі от постійні наші гості,
вже вони як знайомі, вже ми у них гостюємо.
Вони люблять дивитись на наші краєвиди.
Влітку там затока дуже чиста.
Навіть одесити приїжджають купатись.
Водичка у нас із нашої скважини класна тече.
Потім ми з ними біля вогнища можемо посидіти.
Розказуємо наші всі тут легенди місцеві.
Їм подобається там ночувати, в тих наших бунгало.
Ну ми зараз їх ще готуємо.
Після зими. Коли там всередині знаходишся,
залізеш, ніби як лікувальна піраміда.
Дуже гарно себе почуваєш.
Застеляємо, постіль стелимо.
От ці водорості.
Бачите, їх в цій місцевості використовують здавна.
Матраци кладуть.
По-перше, там нічого не заводиться,
по-друге, вони абсолютно не викликають ніякої алергії.
І з другого боку запах моря, йод,
інші такі речовини, сіллю морською пахнуть.
Це дуже корисно.
І воно розслабляє, гарно відпочивати від цивілізації.
Найголовніше.
У нас тут, знаєте таке, ніби шматочок степу.
От зараз підросте і полин, і інші степові рослини.
Ми спеціально привозили і садили їх тут,
ну щоб цікаво було людям.
Ну і якийсь в мене був такий настрій
і я зліпила цю кам'яну бабу.
Вона така не автентична абсолютно,
ви ж бачите, вона не схожа.
Ну мені захотілось її зробити таку,
щоб вона над чимось стояла собі думала.
Коли сюди приїхали, ми знали,
що нам треба буде скошувати траву.
Ну купили спеціально цей інструмент,
бензинову цю косарку
і сусіди бачать, що гарно.
Ми біля двору. «А покосіть і нам».
Інші: «Покосіть і нам там».
Біля магазину, біля церкви покосили.
ПІсля цього один сусід купив,
через деякий [час] ще другий сусід
і ми вже бачимо в нас тут в центрі,
ну голосно сказати — Європа,
але ж гарно, підстрижено все, акуратненько.
У нашій місцевості дерева ростуть погано.
От вже біля цього краю, де закінчуються
наші будинки, там починається пустеля.
Там пісок, а тут ще земля, і тому тут ще дерева ростуть.
І шпанка — це дуже такий популярний
і улюблений сорт вишні в Україні.
Вона рання, великі ягоди, солодкі і дуже соковиті.
Коли зима можна гілочку підійти, відрізати і зварити з неї чай.
Влітку  можна з листочків зварити чай.
Ну а от ми, оскільки вона зараз квітує,
ми приготуємо чай з квіточок.
Рослини Господь створив нам у поміч і в задоволення,
і це не тільки от просто чай, який лікує хвороби.
Це той чай, який дає настрій, дає життєву енергію.
Це лісова груша.
Ідуть в чай не тільки листочки з квіточками,
а гілочки так само, вони мають пори.
І от березові гілочки. Запах.
І це будуть як добавки, наприклад, основний склад —
це буде зніт ферментований
і ми додаємо до нього ці квіточки з дерев.
Наші діти дуже довго сидять
за комп'ютерами, працюють. Так?
І я знайшла такий склад, який допомагає позбутися
застою крові в організмі, коли ти непорушний довго. Так?
І от щоб розганяло кров, щоб спасало від цієї непорушності,
я зробила склад чаю.
Ну а як його назвати? Допомогла донька.
Каже: «Ну як назви...
Мама, а ти знаєш хто такі нерди?». Заучки, так?
Ну це ті, що сидять непорушно
там чи за книжками, чи за комп'ютером.
От тому і чай назвала «Напій для нердів».
Сама я роблю етикетки, розробляю дизайн.
Ну мені це подобається, це довгий шлях.
Знаєте, як на фабриці там кожен робить щось окремо,
а ми все робимо з початку до кінця.
Просто нам це подобається і ми не вживаємо чаї з магазину,
п'ємо тільки свої і гостей пригощаємо.
Ми в принципі називаємо себе дауншифтерами.
Якби скинули високу швидкість на низьку.
І нам інколи здається,
що навіть стрілки годинника в Іванівці
ідуть набагато повільніше,
ніж будь-де в іншому місці.